this has been going on for over a week
what has been overlooked in this story
yeah I mean it's actually 10 days mark
and you know with the world is that it
seemed lean on the wiser for someone
like me that's been on two boards of
inquiry for crass investigation it's
really hard not to start leaning towards
the sort of hijack and the sabotage type
scenarios and and moving away from the
mechanical failure or the pilot error
which you know everything has to be
considered in scenarios such as this so
lead you to believe that I just think if
you'd have asked me up until the point
where we knew the aircraft did a 140
degree turnabout and heading towards the
Malacca Strait I was sort of leaning
towards looking at examples like the Air
France 447 crash where that was icing
the pitot tube it affected the
instruments disconnected itself from the
autopilot to years to find some of the
Branka it absolutely did it took him two
years and and what happened was the
aircraft developed a catastrophic store
that lost a lot of lift the crew didn't
know what was going on no distress call
no emergency code on the transponder and
therefore people were in the dark for
two years as you rightly point out until
the black boxes were found so for me
that was a very viable scenario outcome
until we found out the more sort of
sinister evidence of the aircraft
actually taking 140 degree turn from the
South China Sea and heading to over
towards the Indian Ocean and that to me
was the moment when I thought right
there's this something untoward going on
here let's talk about the emergency
response that was taken by the Malaysian
of Vietnamese air traffic officials when
the squawk that's the code with the
aircraft's position was lost on the
transponder yeah I mean the transponder
does three things it gives you position
through a unique identification code
it's a four-digit code it gives altitude
through the mode charlie and then it
also gives the t caste which is the
traffic collision avoidance system so
it's an incredibly important important
piece of kit on these airlines it's
never turned off and the reasons it's
never turned off is because that piece
of kit alone is responsible for
identifying aircraft during transoceanic
flights and the reason for that is
primary radar you lose primary radar
about 30 minutes crossing the coast into
a transoceanic flight so the transponder
is the only method where air-traffic
controllers around the world can
actually see the aircraft with the
unique identification codes on so since
this information is it streaming live
the the the the transponder score is
absolutely so you'll know the position
of the aircraft now as it happens when
aircraft get to thirty minutes outside
of the coast they all score two thousand
on transoceanic flight so you'll have a
number of aircraft going up and down an
airway in you know across across an
ocean which will be squawking two
thousand at various altitudes and
they're separated through various Mac
numbers that they're told to fly so it's
all procedural basis not radar based at
all communications occurring between
Malaysian civilian and military air
traffic what do we know so far yeah this
to me is the area that was we've still
got a big void of information on if you
look at the point in which the aircraft
turned about and headed towards a
Malacca Strait it was just before
entering Vietnamese airspace now this is
critical because it will be a handover
from Malaysian airspace of Malaysian
authorities to Vietnamese authorities
and what the Vietnamese authorities
would have been asking the Malaysian 370
to do is put a unique identification on
the squawk so 371 identify clear into
the airspace and continue it on route
Beijing the transponder was turned off
before that handover happened and so
what I would like to see a little bit
more of is what emergency procedures
were taken by the Malaysian air traffic
authorities and the Vietnamese air
traffic authorities to try and ascertain
what happened to the aircraft well
aircraft from the transponder was turned
up because it would have disappeared off
primary radar is there anything that
would have alerted others sovereign
radar systems is there's something that
kicks in where they start sending off
alarms well other sovereign radar
systems have what's called generally
have what's called an AI ad so if you
look at Iran they've got a very
sophisticated
Aya's which is a integrated air defense
system and what that is is it's a load
of radars all connected up both civilian
and military and if they get any sort of
of aircraft crossing the sovereign
territory and they're not aware of that
I if the transponders turned off then
they'll all start talking to each other
and if the if the sovereign territory
has what's called a quick reaction alert
fighter capability they'll get some
f-16s or whatever they've got air
defense they'll come up I'll have a look
at it they'll interrogate it and they'll
make sure that obviously it's not a 9/11
scenario that's about so Michael before
I let you go I have to ask you what are
some of the socio-economic factors at
play here particularly as relates to
Malaysia yeah that's a great question I
mean look I I don't think we can apply
that template in this case you know we
talk about socially aware factors sure
to Lebanon in the Middle East Malaysia's
economy is doing really well it's a
Haida middle-income economy it's
actually one of only 13 countries that
achieved a 7 percent GDP growth rate 25
consecutive years in a row from 1967 to
1997 and also it's managed to reduce its
poverty household line from 50 percent
in the 1960s down at 2% now so in terms
of its economy it's doing very well and
I don't think we can really look to
associate socio-economic factors in
terms of the terrorism piece in four
answers as to why this might have
happened